good morning we are here live in the
town of Burnley in Lancashire with some
20 miles north of Manchester we're
basing ourselves all day today in the
church on the street Ministries it's a
charity and it's a church it's really a
drop-in center for anybody everybody is
welcome anybody in need there's hot
meals being served here today people can
come for a hot shower they can get NHS
drop-in center attention mental health
support very many things even haircuts
as well taking place on the other side
of the room now historically Burnley was
a thriving Mill Town so why exactly have
we come here today well it is at the
very sharp end of the cost of living
crisis and we'll just talk you through
some of those figures to explain really
how how Burnley got here
um if you if you look at the data that's
from the center for cities Think Tank it
puts Burnley at the highest rate of
inflation in Great Britain now that
stands here at 11.8 percent that was the
last time it was measured in January
that's some two and a half percent
higher than what you'd find in Cambridge
which is at the other end of the scale
now couple that with one of the slowest
rates of wage growth with the latest
data showing that there's actually
negative real wage growth so strip out
inflation it's negative minus Point 6.6
percent here and the relative child
poverty rate which is an incredibly
Stark indicator that in Burnley stands
at 30. Sam sorry we're just going to
interrupt you there because here comes
the chancellor of the exchequer Jeremy
Hunt to his immediate uh right of course
is John Glenn the chief secretary to the
treasury
[Music]
all right
on your own sir
solution
get the UK growing Chancellor
[Applause]
do you have money to end the strikes
Chancellor
[Music]
is going back to work
so there we have it uh that was uh
Jeremy Hunt the chancellor accompanied
by other treasury ministers there you
saw John Glenn of course the chief
secretary to the treasury Victoria
Atkins the financial secretary to the
treasury and standing next to her of
course Andrew Griffith the city minister
of course someone who's been very very
active in recent weeks not least with
the Edinburgh reforms to the financial
services sector or political
correspondent Tamara Cohen is uh is with
us so tomorrow there we go that's the
big set piece event of budget day of
course or one of them
yes of course of course Jeremy Hunt
doing his his first budget of course he
was thrown into it when he became a
Chancellor during the Autumn statement
which he said was intended to deliver
stability after the turbulent Liz truss
period in office and today he says his
mission will be delivering economic
growth of course we all assume we're
about 18 months out from a general
election and he's got the challenges of
helping people struggling with the cost
of living and on that we expect a big
expansion of help with child care for
one and two-year-olds and additional
help with energy bills for another three
months but of course he's also got to
try and get the economy growing the
predictions are pretty Grim for the
coming years if we don't slip into
recession it certainly looks like
flatlining and he will he's under
pressure from conservative MPS to try
and cut taxes for business we think he
won't be doing that in terms of
corporation tax that was likely to go up
but he will be announcing investment
zones and tax breaks for businesses of
the future so whether it meets the
demands on helping with the cost of
living and also delivering growth those
will be the two challenges that Jeremy
Hunt faces today